so we over here in Australia we've got
we've got three time zones right do you
do it there okay so the ones where is
the one we're in the ones we are at are
well we are currently in a second season
which is Australian
I insist at a time why is Darryl why
there a new problem why don't you try to
deny writer there of anybody's different
because sometimes soldiers wiggle 80s
people judgment a DST what's that
Sheriff
Ethan there are savings time you might
complain now other important ones
I'll get the GOP the second I want to
look at Australia first I by the way you
can do this if you want um just work
with time zone map I think and you
cannot for instance if I go here then
Alice Springs
well I click my now stream that was
nothing is sorry in the country is there
a okay anybody want a derby sing there
we go okay so if I come back I keep
clicking on it oh that's okay it's a CST
and CSU if it's an L sprinkle you get
that reverses essential things
okay then here is huh advert I'm
suggesting the name of the time to edit
residues 830's AWS - for visionary
questions next time okay now we were
alluding to a few others the GMT is
Greenwich Mean Time but it's not called
G ot anymore officially even though we
keep on set I mean I think it's a fairly
uh it's nice because then you know where
they thought it's denser Greenwich Mean
Time
but what we've replaced it with is UTC
which I looked up just that I didn't
else look it up now it's a it's an
alternative is it awkward acronym it's
an to a universal time coordinated we're
just done I don't know it but it feels
get weird when Brown Oh
so that GGC Sanergy emptied everything
else is measured in relation to it so if
I come back all the time
absolutely keep clicking forward on the
map you can see everything is measured
in relation to this so this really needs
instead of time is UTC Universal Time
but it's gone forward you can see how
far it's going forward you see that so
we are ten hours ahead of whatever the
time is Greenwich at least we are right
now if we're a daylight savings time
that's ignorant to adjuster them so we
are plus them which means as we go
further west you can see our Springs
Australian digital map the lifeline and
it portrays showing West instead of time
they'll be plus eight is Ellington uh
you know look what else do you see
there's also plot hence have a look
what's there so I want to point out a
few things here of Russia Russia is huge
I don't know you people don't really
think that much about Rush
comes from relationship with them Russia
is NASA's like it stretches from pretty
short
this red one no no this this looks here
oh yeah I was right
so here is the most western part of
Russia for any history but um this this
over here is that brought up where arm
he'll try to go with it and big rush up
and fail because too cold you've got
Russia and it goes all the way across
here over to that eastern section which
show goes off to touch Alaska or August
anyway so look at all the different
colors and you can see all of the time
zones that Russia passes through because
it's huge however even though it goes
through all of these different times
then you notice this one which goes
across I think it's five actual time
zone but it's all green we talked about
it's just that with it this is China
right so everyone in China is operating
on Beijing time even though I think
Beijing is sort of around here and these
days are like 3,000 kilometers west
still the same time with their clocks
okay okay so so those countries even
example are you talking about like which
ones are cookies you do this like that
and it is more that way that is same
time it's a little less it left Lebanon
yeah yep you'd only relative you yeah
yes they have the same
no way just run out of colors that's all
there's this red on color so as well as
I could have had will change mr. Carter
to three okay so does that make sense
you see how these their time zones work
so all you want to think about is figure
out the breeches which is cuties here
right UTC is in line with up with great
written up event and then as you travel
west you've got less time and as you
travel east you've got more time right
to the time the head or the time is
behind is that because okay account
already oh no you just look at th
where's your Facebook your example
mission is that the pollyanna yeah so we
don't do that because crazy it's like
I've got a little bit in my washing
you're not going to I catch on the topic
unanswered covers all right thank you
option question are there certain degree
what a degree memory question what's the
degree on the earth we can work this out
so there's actually called back to a
previous exercise we're doing we're
working the distances between places or
different or on the table between on the
same latitude okay so let's think about
this way before we get these questions
because this is really in one question
to answer if you got the earth here and
you're too long which is that are only
one degree apart noticeability quite
close together like that so I'm going to
go one degree like that and work out how
far apart they're if they're all the
same latitude has to be able to same
latitude
say if they are on the equator okay
let's work out this distance so this is
a bit tricky so watch out if you think
about the equator here I've just sliced
across the earth so near the equator and
you've got these two spots are just
going to exaggerate it cuz otherwise I
told you I'd never see them and there
are only one degree apart okay if I went
360 degree I would get the whole
circumference of the equator would know
right
so if I went three or six degrees I'd
get that whole business but I'm only
going one degree I'm really going 1
degree so therefore I don't want the
whole circumference only one one 360 of
that circumference now we didn't form
the first conference is two five
ah right where R is the radius of the
circle but we go actually what the
radius of this is I didn't point this
out before but I might as well go on
your for analogy the radius of Earth is
provided to you it says take it as sick
as a voyage colonists why do they say
that cuz it's not exactly of sphere so
this is a bit like mountains and
knowledgeable
but we say that's close enough so we
have a look at this that you will value
okay
can we wake up in this can you graduate
accolades and other senses okay so this
is how far this is how far you would
have to change your so you how to drive
or fly to change four bits on your site
so yeah this is not going to like it
doesn't happen straight way to take you
an hour at 110 KS / L on a highway over
an Australian straight across by the way
down I just want to point out something
tricky progress something for you which
is that I'm come back to the globe
mm-hmm do you remember I mentioned to
you then I'll forget the circumference
of ether the reason I can do that is
because this circle here is not just 800
via it's a great circle
do you remember what makes the great
circle a great circle it passes right
through the centre which also means it's
the biggest a circle could possibly be
much lighter you cross okay now think
about this fresh air let's have a look
at the Arctic Circle okay so here's our
circle now if I see a similar type thing
right and I wanted to see when our fire
part is 1 degree but somewhere up here
do you see I'm not going to get a great
circle or the latitudes the power the
latitude or small up here right so
therefore if I drew a circle up here
right so Andres 2-1 degree between the
voltages it's much closer together do
you see that right if I imagine a that a
little
let's put a couple of mortgages in one
fire pot so they don't want to repot
let's say we weren't that problem okay
it's objectively easy to see that this
distance here is going to be different
to this distance and this distance is
the distance because the longer tune is
remember
then don't parallel they all intersect
up here right as they're down here so
therefore they get closer to question
closer together so this distance is more
degree on the equator you'd have to work
out something different for wherever we
are
sorry there we go because the parallel
of latitude we are on is going to be
smaller it will be one of the small
circles does that make sense so this is
on the equator and we should probably
actually write that data people if
you've written the rest of your working
that I have this is equivalent to one
degree less to do but please Paulo fire
it on the equator that's why we did that
exercise you may not advertise this so
we didn't yet how that work in the
distance out between two different spots
they always gave it to you on the same
longitude right because every Meridian
longitude is a great circle so you can
do this they never asked you to work out
distances on the same LAN Chi because
it's much trickier you're going to have
different radii for all of those
different circles because they're
different